well some of the brightest minds in the
world are fans of books by our next
guest myself included Israeli historian
you've all know a Harare explored the
past and future of humanity and his book
sapiens and Homo Deus they became
international bestsellers with more than
12 million copies sold worldwide his
books were also praised by a wide range
of thought leaders including former
President Barack Obama Bill Gates Mark
Zuckerberg and Sir Richard Branson in
his new book 21 lessons for the 21st
century
Harare focuses on the present and died
sex the most pressing issues facing
humanity you've all know Harare good
morning great to have you on
congratulations on the book so much of
what we're talking about now and in the
future is based on technology and AI and
a big question many people have is will
they I helped us as a race will they
help us as a society or will AAA I'll
eat you are down Paul well that depends
on our question on on what we do with it
I mean technology is not deterministic
you can build very different societies
with the same technology just as you
could use trains and electricity and
radio to build communist dictatorships
or fascist regimes or liberal
democracies in the 20th century so also
in the 21st century
you can use AI in biotechnology to build
paradise or hell it's up to us and what
about the jobs though I mean the one of
the stories leading up to this interview
was about the need to retrain workers
and the the feared loss of jobs due to
automation what what can we expect in
decades to come when it comes to jobs
what we can expect two things I mean the
job market will completely change and
much of the struggle that people will
have will be against irrelevance and not
exploitation yeah you said there's a
real risk that we could create a massive
useless class of people yeah that's the
biggest risk that many people will lose
completely their economic value and
therefore also the political power now
there will be of course new jobs some
jobs will disappear many jobs will
disappear many jobs will emerge the big
question is whether people will be
able to retrain and reinvent themselves
in time and whether they can do it again
and again and again because if you have
a 50 60 year career as life expectancy
also increases you will have to do it
not just once you know some people think
that the AI revolution will be some big
event following which the job market
will settle into a new equilibrium but
it is very unlikely the AI revolution
will likely be a cascade of ever bigger
disruptions so you will have to reinvent
yourself repeatedly and here the biggest
question that the biggest problem may be
psychological yes whether people have
the mental ability to reinvent
themselves at age 40 and again at 50 and
again in 16 and you say we're not we're
not teaching we're not preparing kids
for this in school no not at all and
most of what kids learn today in school
will probably be irrelevant by the time
they're 40 or 50 and we don't really
know what to teach them because nobody
knows how the job market or the world
would look like in 2050 it's maybe the
first time in history we have no idea
whatsoever how the job market would look
like in 30 years
yeah so the best bet is to focus on
emotional intelligence and mental
stability and mental resilience and how
do you suggest people do that I don't
know you meditate you meditate every day
that's one of the ways you do I meditate
I do Vipassana meditation two hours a
day I go for a 60 days retreat a few
hours a day yeah and because of that I
know how difficult it is and it's not
easily scalable and it's much more
difficult to teach emotional
intelligence or mental resilience than
to teach physics equations or to teach
history or whatever and we don't have
the tools at present to scale up this
kind of teaching so most of what we see
in most schools is just inertia we do
what was relatively okay in the 20th
century mm-hmm we're still I mean your
point is we're still kind of stuffing
kids full of information that they now
can get pretty easily themselves what we
what we need to do is teach them how to
evaluate that information that's part of
the thing and it's not what I say it's
it's almost all experts on education
would agree information is the last
thing the kids need they have foul to
much of it anyway yeah and censorship
today works in a very different way in
the past
censorship worked by blocking the flow
of information and information was very
valuable today censorship works by
flooding people with enormous amounts
not just of this information conflicting
conflicting information and simply
irrelevant information and one of the
questions you raised is who's gonna own
that information who's gonna be owning
that data in the future as well yeah
that's maybe the biggest political
question I mean in in ancient times land
was the most important asset in the
economy so politics was the struggle to
control land in the last 200 years
machines replaced land as the most
important economic asset so politics
became the struggle to control the
machines and now data is replacing
machines as the most important asset so
politics is really a struggle about who
owns and who controls the flows of data
in the world so much to think about
you've all know or Harare thank you so
much thank you
thank you 21 lessons for the 21st
century goes on sale tomorrow